Okay, sir.
Damn it.
Akshay.
Hello.
Akhilesh.
I hope George joins.
Love you.
Okay.
Please drop him a drop him an email.
Ohh.
Mm.
Hey, we got Rodge. Hey, Rodge.
George.
Morning, George.
Hello.
Morning.
We were just about to drop you a message. How are you doing this morning?
How are you doing?
Oh, yeah. Good, good. Just busy. I was on another call and I looked at the clock. I'm like, oh, ****. So apologies for being late.
No.
Understandable.
But...
George B. Aman is off sick, so he had to go through a minor surgery during the weekend. So that is the reason we have Akhilesh today covering for him. I'm sure that Akhilesh, you've met George in the past, right? Yeah, it's okay. So it doesn't need introduction then.
Okay.
Up.
Ault.
Oh yeah.
Hey, George, how you doing?
I can show it.
Good, how are you?
Got to.
Okay, perfect. So yeah, just wanted to quickly run through how with the previous review data and trackers. However, before just presenting the screen and everything, I would just like to hear from you in case if you have any feedback, any suggestions, or anything related to Noyle's performance.
Yeah, I, I don't, I don't have any.
I don't have any negative feedback at all. This is our first month without Seguna and I feel like, I think everything's going very well and the guys have all stepped up. I'm curious to see and hear the numbers because I feel like they've done a great job.
Uh-huh.
Okay, thank you. Thank you for the feedback. And anything pending which you are awaiting from Aman that I can help with till the time he is not available?
Not right now. I had a project with him to move over contracts from one system. Well, I really just needed him to build out our products and services and then the bundles so that I can go apply contracts to, so I can apply contracts to
customers. Because we're trying to move everything away from our current, we use this system called Blue Billing right now and we want to move everything into auto task. And so I know a while back we had started that conversation, but I've been tight on money and so I haven't pushed the envelope, but I think I'm ready to
Who?
Kind of push back on that and see if we can we can get a scope of work built.
Perfect. Yeah, thank you. And let me know in case if you need any help over there. I know that there was a to do which was pending from one side which regarding the project details for Entra ID setup, I think, and initiating the collaboration within the team for going ahead with that.
Okay.
Right, I forgot about that one. Okay, I need to get, I need to look at that scope of work and get that, because we did talk about that and it was accurate. I just need to get that over to the customer and get it signed off on.
Soap.
Yeah, so George, just for clarity, right, going through the action items. So the entire IT project, I think the scope of the work was already shared with you. And then I think you had a query which Aman did answer. So is it a sign off that you are waiting on from your customer so that we can move ahead?
Yes.
Yes, correct. So that is still alive.
Okay, so okay, so we will wait for your go ahead so that, you know, once you have the sign off and once you have agreed to the SW, of course, we can commence with the project from our side. And the second project that you are talking about, is this something that you have already scoped with Aman, or is it something that you would want us to set up a separate call in the coming week?
to go through separately.
I feel like we already scoped it, but let me write out a brief scope of work just to redefine it, and I'll email that to...
Okay.
Sure.
Antonio.
Yeah, yeah, if you could email it across to us, that would be great. OK, of course, you know, one of the tasks that we had was providing you with an additional engineer, but of course, that is that is not moving ahead, so yeah.
that's there. Any new clients that you're onboarding charge?
None at the moment, but I've got some, I've got some, how's the saying? I got some irons in the fire. One is a pretty big one.
Okay.
Okay, good news.
It's about 800 employees for 400 and...
It's healthier.
And then I've got another 30 seat that I'm actually meeting with today. They've got like.
Kam.
almost a dozen VMs. And so we're gonna, actually one of the scopes of work I might end up sending you is to.
Mhm.
They have on-site exchange server and we want to move them to 365.
OK.
Okay.
Sure.
But let me, let me get their approval to even quote it out, but I'll have that by noon today.
Sure, yeah, if we can, once you have the confirmation, do let us know and accordingly we can move forward. Okay, lastly, George, we talked about your presence at Build It. I know we already had a discussion about it. Anything that we can support you with?
Okay.
I know it's a great event, right? I mean, from an overall value proposition, and given that your association has been long-term with us, and you've been associated with the isolator, et cetera. So what is it one thing that we can do to get you over to build it?
Let me close a couple deals and get some cash flow back.
OK, is it?
I just, I really, I just really need to not spend money right now.
Understood. Is it the flight ticket which is bothering you, hotel, or the registration?
No.
Oh.
It's the need for me to focus.
I mean, in the interest of partnership, right? I can... Okay, sorry, go ahead. Complete the thought.
No, I was just going to say it's really just the time factor and the focus. I need to get back to the basics.
Yeah.
and make sure the business is back to a stable point. And then I can, and I'm thinking that's only three to six months, and then I can start looking at, you know, the, I'll use the word, the accelerator aspects, you know, things to improve the business.
I mean, one of the perspectives that I had, George, was, right, at Build It, you'll be meeting about 92% of the decision makers, the C-suites, across the MSP, right? And you can have a one-on-one sessions with them. There will be a lot of...
conversations that you can have, which is with the C-suite, rather than having a conversation with somebody who's not a decision maker. So essentially talking about your level, right? And that might open up a lot of opportunities for you is what I was thinking that might accelerate the overall effort that you're making right now.
to get some more business across.
So that was the perspective that we were coming from. I know that you are trying to focus on the business, but at the same time, we also understand, right, that the more contacts you have, the more close contacts and interactions you have, the more value you would be able to probably generate. And of course, like I said.
You are a valued partner. I mean, if it is the flight ticket which is bothering you, if it is the cost of the build it registration which is bothering you, anything of that sort, if you can let us know. I mean, of course, I can go back with Sarbjeet and have a word with the management and see what is the best that we can come back to you with. We are down to do anything and everything which is possible.
to get you over and purely because of the fact of, you know, the partnership and the opportunity that you may come across and build it.
Okay.
Okay, what's the date of build it? Just so I can refresh myself.
Oh, that is...
That's August 3rd to August 5th. And that's happening at New Jersey Hyatt. For your quick reference, George, I'm sending you the link in the chat right away so that you can go through it. After this call, I'll go ahead and send you the details over a separate email too.
Yep.
But.
Kam.
Okay.
OK.
Support for you.
Okay.
Yeah, I mean, George, it's all about, you know, we've been very closely working with you and I think there's no hesitation in terms of talking to you to see what is the best that we can do, right? It has, this is how the relationship has been overall, right? So I was more down to speaking to anybody.
to make sure that we are able to do whatever is needed. Ankur was also checking about you, right? He was also trying to speak to you. We had a conversation this morning specifically, right, when we were going through the registration list, and of course, your name popped up, and it was like, okay, George is not coming over. What can we do?
Okay.
to get him over. Please check and let's make it happen. So.
Well, the big problem that I now see is my wife's birthday is August 5th, so maybe you guys should talk to her and not me.
Oh my God.
New Jersey is the best city to celebrate the birthday, George. That's the best place to celebrate the birthday, I guess.
That's rather a bigger surprise.
Yeah.
And just one thing, George, which I would specifically like to add in over here. On August 5th, specifically, we have our grand party. We are taking the first 300 partners to New York Stock Exchange. And the party is between 5 to 7 P.m. That's based specifically on great
Gatsby team. So definitely I would love to say that you can check. It will be a great birthday present.
Yeah.
Yeah, I, yeah, New York Stock Exchange is, I mean, I'm sure you know that, right? I mean, getting entry is like, is a big task. And of course, we are able to spend the evening. And yeah, that certainly is going to be a special gift for her if you want to bring her along. And yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Anything that we can do from our side, we are down to it.
Okay, yeah, let me take a look at it and I can get back to you, Aman.
Yeah.
Sure, sure, George. We'll continue to follow up and we, Sarbjeet, will get back to you shortly with anything, you know, reduced that we can do from our side with a coupon code and offer codes, et cetera. And even if after that, if you see there is anything that you specifically need to talk to us about.
Drop me an email or Sarbjeet an email. We can quickly connect and take it forward.
Okay.
Yeah.
Quacherra.
The idea is to see you there, George, at any cost, right? So, yeah, so fantastic. Over to you, Akhilesh.
Yes.
Thank you. I'll continue with my presentation. Let me know once you guys see the screen.
Got it.
Thank you once again for joining our monthly business review. And in absence of Aman, just do let me know if I miss out on something. I would definitely include it over here.
So the agenda remains the same, so no changes over here. We'll go through quick check-in, highlights, and the performance analysis, which is the topmost priority that we do. And at the end, we have voice of customer, action tracker, and recaps, where we recalculate everything which we discussed. So for the highlights,
So daily board review, which has been going on for the engineers. So earlier, 2 engineers were there. Now it is only for Noel. And Noel is already working on his level up, which is including his skill set and going above for the technical skill sets. So he's working on that and we'll let you know once he completes it.
Then we have got the positive C set for the month of May and I believe for June we'll be sending out the service soon.
Okay.
For the action tracker, I think we discussed about the project detail for entry ID. Noyles renewal notification, I think that has been completed. And then there is AI accelerator program and the enrollment code. I just wanted to know from you, is it done or you are still looking for that?
The for the enrollment code.
Yep.
I thought I saw it pop through on the meeting here, but I'm opening my Team right now, so I should see it.
Ohh.
Yeah, that's something that we will send a revised one. Sarbjeet will be sending a revised one, George. Yeah, so that'll have some discounted X, yeah, additional discounts that we can use.
Oh.
Sure.
Okay.
And.
Thanks. And George, the third day for the Build It event for August 5th specifically, we are dedicating that day to the AI Excalator program. So earlier we have those quarterly events. So this time we are included it in the third day of the event itself.
Okay.
No.
Okay, I'll share the agenda with you. Let us go through the deck 1st and after this call I'll share the agenda. What's happening on which day, what are the boots so that it will be easier for you.
Okay.
Sure.
Perfect. Thank you, sir. I'll just quickly go into our performance analysis. So this is how it looks like for the last month, which is from May 25th to June 26th. So yeah, we have seen a positive improvement of 15% in the billable utilization.
Overall billable utilization for Noel was 59%, which was positive side from 15%, I believe, from the last month which we had. And I think that it is due to the fact that we have only one engineer now, so the workload is not getting distributed.
And there is a reason, however, we are still very much aligned to get it up to 80%, which is our target as of now.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah, ticket counts have been good. I mean, this team has been really good at resolving right away and not closing tickets too early. So I think it's really brought down the...
Mhm.
The ticket count.
Yep, perfect. I'll just talk about the ticket utilization analysis or trend on the next. So yeah, there's the graph that you see on the left hand side has got the number of tickets that has been closed and the target which we had for every week. So where you see 32?
That is the.
40 is the for one week that we have, 8 tickets per week, per day for one week. However, where you see 32 or 24, it means that the engineer was leave for either one day, two day, or three day. So it is according to that. However, we have seen that he has closed around 223 tickets out of.
Right.
253 which was assigned to him and which is comprehensive of 88% of closure rate. So yeah, ticket count is good. He's working on the closure rate as well. And yeah, over the target well above. And definitely we can just move across once the utilization is getting into the stable position. And while Saguna is away, definitely he is just taking charge of all other things as well.
Okay.
Norton.
Okay, I think yeah, this is uh...
two factors that we do discuss. Anything else that you would like to see on these trends or analysis, please do let us know because we will be able to just accumulate anything that you want to see as per the ticket trends or any sort of other aspect that you want to see as a KPI.
I know that KPI has already been discussed, but yes, in case if you just go over with any set of other KPIs that needs to be included, please do let us know.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, and for the customer satisfaction index, we have received the May CSAT, so it was positive for both the engineers. And as discussed earlier, so June CSAT will be sending out soon.
Okay.
Yeah, I think for the operations point of view, these were the three slides and the next slides are of the marketing, which is the AI by design.
Yeah, we can skip those, I think, for now.
Team GPS and then we have built it, which we already discussed. So yeah, that was all from my end. I know that it was very pretty small and considering that Aman is away, I did not have much. But yeah, do let me know if I have missed something and if in case we need to share anything else. Just.
Yeah.
Good.
Topping the presentation and over to you.
Okay. I think I just need, I need to review the Entre ID scope of work.
The.
And possibly OU.
A scope of work for the Exchange Server to 365, and then I was gonna write a scope of work for auto task billing.
But.
Yep.
OK.
and take a look at BuildIt.
I, I have my notes.
No.
George, would you like me to share some more details regarding the build it, the agenda, if you have a few minutes available?
Yeah, I have a couple minutes. We can go through that.
Oh, here. So just to quickly bring it up on the screen, these are the dates. That's August 3rd to 5th. And 5th, definitely, that's really important for us. For talking about the persons, we have more than 500 plus MSP leaders there.
92% will be for the SISU decision makers, channel influencers, 45 platform CEOs, and the average revenue for this MSP will be from 30 million, from 10 million to 30 million. There is a small video over here. These are some of the speakers who will be coming in from the MSP world. We have.
Thank you.
Habib from the MSP Corp team, Red Helm, Focus Technologies, R3 logically, all of these will be there in terms of the speakers and collaborators. Talking about the price, I have already given you the complimentary code where you have one free ticket, buy one, get one free. That's there in case if you
It.
would like to bring more from your team, just let me know. I'll see to it what the best can be done for us. Talking about the New York Stock Exchange, the one which I was discussing with you, that's happening on Wednesday from 7 to 9 P.m. That's Wall Street, New York City, where we'll be taking the first 300.
Thank you.
Kip.
Partners who will be able to RSVP themselves for this event, and the dress code is on the Great Gatsby event, so obviously you need to get the things ready accordingly. These are the list of agenda, so we have a one Pre Day event for our AI accelerator program, and then for third day...
It will come.
After the Kam and Sunny's keynote, we are going with Tim Barton, who is from Hello PSA. Then we have four different breakout sessions for dedicated teams, which is specifically focused on AI, the kind of implementation which we have done internally. For example, dispatch agents, QBR agents, so.
Yeah.
Those will be definitely there. Leadership, operations, growth, and sales. So that's what would be there in the breakout session. Similarly, on August 4th, the day starting at 8 A.m., then we'll have the breakout sessions for all the four different leadership teams. And then last day, that's dedicated specifically for the AI accelerator.
Pritam.
where you will be working with Zach from the OpenAI team. So we have the morning session, then afternoon sessions, and these are specifically the hands-on workshop where you will be building the tools themselves. And last but not the least, the tools, the templates will be shared with you so that you can get it implemented within your organization.
itself. So any query related to this in terms of agenda or the hotel booking?
No, this all looks good. Everything's here.
Awesome. And because the FIFA is also ongoing, so 10th July, I believe that's the time when the hotels are filling up fast. So something which I wanted to make sure you are aware about. So if you need any help with the hotel registration as well, do let me know. I'm just a
Yeah.
Text away to help you with it.
Okay, perfect. Thank you.
I think.
And we are coordinating George for the coupon codes to see if there's anything more that can be done from our side. We'll shortly get back to you on that one.
Okay, thank you.
I'm sorry.
Rest, I believe I'm all good. George, anything else from your end?
No, I've got the website up for Build It. I was just kind of browsing through. I think everything's good. I'll get you a couple of scopes of work. I'll review one. We'll go from there.
Perfect.
Thank you, George, and I'll just put it across over the email so that you have the recap for the today's meeting and with all the to-dos that you have on you and what we have on us.
Alright.
Thank you so much.
Awesome. Thanks guys. Have a great week.
Perfect. Thank you. Bye.
Thanks. Thank you, George. Take care. Bye.
Thank you, Team.